everything's going to be player one
ready I can't wait that's what it'll be
like right I I digital currency people
are going to be in their headsets I
think I think I think VR is real to be
yeah it's going to be 20 years but it's
real like if I if I want to sit into a
therapist office but she's in New York
I'm going to get on the VR and have a
therapy session like I mean that's
you're pretty much already there with
that you just took the [__] words out
of my mouth perfect job good work cuz
they're gateways Zoom is the middle step
to that mhm I mean you could put on an
Oculus right now go to zoom.com and yeah
the only problem is one day the Oculus
will look like this and you're just like
hello you're reading AR like even better
one day Oculus is going to look like
this like an contact yeah like have you
seen the movie Anon I have not buten I
know the punch line I mean you're
walking down the street and it's just
like a digital profile everybody walks
by AR is amazing yeah AR is [__]
amazing by the way the new rayb band
meta Facebook thing oh where you could
just hit the uh dude it's [__] fresh
the fact that they did that from one
year to the next year
it's going to speed up I love when
people think that the moment they're
living in is when technology stops no no
I'll go for this iPhone is going to look
like a [__] beeper in 20 years for
sure yeah well it's going to be the once
neurolink takes off if it does like
that's going to be a game changer but it
it would be weird to implant a chip into
your brain I would do it you let me tell
you when I would do it I would do it I'm
a second wave guy
I wouldn't be the first first dude to do
it because I be like what's up with the
cancer but if you gave me a few minutes
of it and I understood I'm definitely
not going to be the hold out like I'm
gonna like why not yeah like I don't
know like what do you think chip in your
brain that's kind of weird concept I get
it but like people put [__] in their
heart and that was a weird concept to
people 70 years ago yeah when people
were like yo we can fix everyone was
dying of heart attacks back in the day
and then they're like we're going to cut
you open and put a [__] thing on your
heart I would have been like [__] you
yeah Amazon when you could pay with your
pal at first I was like [__] that I just
saw that for the first time
yesterday I want everyone to know
everything I want everything to be
frictionless I was like of course
blockchain wait to deep fake videos come
out do you understand that we just did a
full pledge interview and in four years
kids are going to [__] around and change
the [__] we said on this and it's going
to look like we said it well have you
seen the on Tik Tok they're taking
aren't they already doing that doing
that with podcast of course they're like
hey my dick got bigger it's like him and
but they're changing his voice to sell
their product that's right yeah so what
happened is the last 100 years video has
been I would argue video has been the
judge and jury of our society if you see
it on video It Happened JFK did get
assassinated Rodney K get did get beat
like the Yankees did like video was the
proof we're about to go into the era of
where you don't believe a single video
over the next decade all the videos
we're not going to see and then people
going to understand why the blockchain
matters because this episode in a three
years you're not going to post on
YouTube first you're going to post on
your blockchain address first iio that's
right to show that this was real and
then go up and then when I find on the
internet I don't know if this doesn't
exist yet from my knowledge base they're
going to connect those two things the
blockchain's about to get uncomfortably
uncomfortably important cardono baby all
the way to the Moon do you see what the
that's the for what the what the
blockchain does is nobody owns the
service everyone everyone's like America
China Russia everyone's like Facebook
Tik Tok all controlled now good good
news there's something called the
blockchain nobody controls the servers
that's the place of truth and obviously
the nft craziness of two summers ago
that happened just like internet stocks
in in the first wave people got crazy
because this new thing things get
overvalued because greed and
Ridiculousness takes over it gets
reconnected corrected excuse me and then
you start to build the aftermath of the
2000 stock crash of all the internet
companies was 99% of the husters went
away and went back to Banking and being
a lawyer and the 1% that actually gave a
[__] built the Amazon and the paypals
and the ebays and the [__] that [__]
actually mattered wa here here's the
pattern how I know blockchain is going
to pop off is when you start seeing sign
that says we are no longer a cashless
cash business that's right you're like
well what is it it's like oh they want
you on your phone well it's so funny a
buddy of mine was like really passionate
like a year and a half ago when this
combo was hot he's going to get me at
dinner and he goes into he would [__]
I felt like he did a lot a lot of
homework I was proud of him like some
good points he goes how could you trust
it like how do you know that's your cash
how can you trust it you have to hold it
and I was like I was like what's in your
pocket and he's like what and he like so
I got his wallet out I go that's a
credit card how do you trust that I'm
like do you understand this the same
conversation that happened in 1960 when
people were talking about credit cards
are coming and all these could you
imagine dudes in the 60s all those
characters with real money like [__] you
it's all cash I don't want people
knowing my [__] cash cash cash I mean
there's still people like that today of
course but but today like it's I laugh
when people like well how do you know
where your money is I'm like where's
your money right now yeah where the
[__] your money right now losing 7%
under your mattress a year crazy yeah
[__] t- bills now like it's crazy
like it's a it's listen all this shit's
interesting first of all I just want to
say not that I'm wrapping it up I still
got time but I'm enjoy I'm enjoying the
[__] out of this but yeah I I I got to
pee like crazy and uh we crushed it
we've been doing it for a while I know
we we got an hour and a half oh we
[__] annihilated I think this is good
that's a lot to ask of the audience if
you went Coast to Coast I [__] love
you I say that at the end of every
episode I say our street team to the
street team well we should give away
something on your website for the people
that are listening to the very end you
want to do something um oh I like that
little call to add give away something
uh you want to I'll give some I would
like to um how about how about I create
a a a special URL and and put the bucket
list on there for free whoa like uh just
real quick like you got to be the the
first people to this you going to do it
for like a week you know what that's
going to get me a breach of
contract I'll I'll jump in all right go
I'll jump in you guys create a URL you
can post produce this afterwards but you
get me the the 25 people that did it
their name and address and I'll just
send them a ton of [__] we could do that
too we can do that go to the botom Sur
surprise boxes go to the bottom of
sto.com love it and uh with the on the
on the customer support just say Gary V
is going to send me some [__] in the
title yeah yeah in your title and then
leave your your your name and address
and the first 25 people5 over that that
if this has been up for more than two
hours the ship is yeah the ship is sa
probably sa they probably number
26 right that's great for creating
incentive for people to get on it
quicker so that everybody wins just fun
like so fun just nice to do fun [__] by
the way Tik Tock live I'm telling you
right now here's why first of all Let Me
Tell let me I'm just gonna add a little
more value Instagram live you go on
Instagram pings the people that follow
you they all come on and then as I'm
sure you know it decreases over time
yeah right because everyone comes they
get pinged and and they decrease makes
sense like an email like fine they see
what's going on okay I've seen yeah they
hang for as long as they can and they
got a bounce but because you had a full
flood and then it declines Tik Tok goes
the other way Tik Tok the longer you're
on the more they're s surfacing you're
live even nonf followers too right
especially non-followers yeah Instagram
doesn't even do that Instagram doesn't
do non-followers so so you go on for an
hour you guys do what you got to I mean
this is the last thing you guys have to
worry about yeah it's all going to be
predicated on good ideas fun ways to do
it you have unlimited ways everything
from just wanting to do it by yourself
for an hour and talk about it to like
you producing cool ideas I don't have
any worry about that but you do it a lot
here's the best part also then you get
to chop up little pieces from it where
there's Tik Tok will show you where the
spikes were of interest you clip it and
you run those as Tik Tok and Instagram
and Facebook and YouTube short ads to
sell the stuff so you're basically
creating a production day to create good
ads while you're selling [__] on a Tik
Tok live it's crazy it's [__] crazy
you're basically let me use it in old
school terms you're basically doing a
QVC show that's randomly showing up to
people who don't know who you are and
for that you get to see the data that
shows you what commercials you should
make for your product on all the other
platforms great
that's great are you are you still on
the same tip as uh um posting as much as
you can all day every day yeah I think I
think there's like push-ups if you do 30
push-ups you get 30 push-up results yeah
you do 100 push-ups you get 100 now what
people don't hear what I say it back to
things I say that maybe I need to do a
better job breaking down which is why
I'm writing this book or I or I'm hoping
people can hear what I'm saying when I
say post 30 times a day I'm also saying
post on seven platforms yes and I'm also
saying tweak it slightly based on a
platform so for example I think y'all
should post a lot more on
LinkedIn that doesn't seem native or
natural but meanwhile LinkedIn is
getting a ton of organic reach and
because most of it is business content
but people are in it all day long now
like Facebook anything that's somewhat
out of the ordinary does even better and
let's call it Spade of spade a lot of
people in LinkedIn are in their 40s and
50s who are like real fans of you mhm
it's like a good demo for you wow so
like all of a sudden think 30 now 30
posts a day all of a sudden if you're
just posting on Instagram and YouTube
that's like 30 a day that's [__] up
but when you're posting on are you guys
posting on Snapchat
Spotlight there you go I know trust me I
know I'm watching everything Snapchat's
got unbelievable reach if you know what
you're doing YouTube shorts versus just
YouTube LinkedIn is now if you say when
you know what you're doing like are
there different strategies for of like
different from snap social media content
strategy is the hardest marketing craft
in the world mhm YouTube shorts is where
M or media yeah but that's super
expensive and for big companies that's
why I'm trying to put out as much that's
why every five or 10 I wrote a book
about 10 years ago called jab jab jab
right hook and to this day I get 10
emails a day like head of marketing this
marketing that entrepreneur like that
book and I I went like a huge rally of
it a couple months ago just randomly
just hearing from a lot of people of how
much that book changed her life and I
was like man how are and then even new
people like I just read it it's so great
I'm like [__] man it's so outdated so I
started writing a new book called jab
jab jab left took oh great but then when
I went through it I realized this is
much more complex so it's it's been
renamed to day trading attention cuz
that's what I do I day trade attention
I'm giving you platform strategy right
now but I'm also paying attention to
everything that's happening in pop
culture why are people wearing corduroy
hats why did Alex Earl pop on Tik Tok
why did liquid death work who's the
upand cominging rapper what food is
working like shoes sneakers like why
like I like why did vans cross over from
skateboard West Coast Coast kids to
black kids in the urban world like why
why why why so I live in that both on
platform and on culture once you
understand those things you can dominate
do you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is sto's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get sto's hot sauce fre your butthole
plus sto's butthole Destroyer and sto's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right
now yeah dude